one of the best things about staying
home from school as a kid was watching
daytime court shows my personal favorite
the People's Court Judge million is
electric and the cases are always so
ridiculous but what if I told you that
this is not an actual courtroom and when
a person loses a case they don't even
have to pay the settlement so what's
actually going on court shows have long
been a staple of American television but
they didn't start on TV the first court
shows popped up in radios Golden Age the
early programs were typically
reenactments of real court cases but the
People's Court which began in 1981
started a whole new era arbitration
based reality shows presiding since 2001
Judge Marilyn Milian is the show's
longest-serving host and the first
Latina judge toes the nationally
syndicated court show before the
People's Court Milian was an assistant
state attorney in Florida and was
appointed by Governor Jeb Bush to the
Miami Circuit Court working in the
Criminal Division I had a gubernatorial
appointment and it was a sure thing
and I had crossed every T and dotted
every eye to make sure that I had an
upward trajectory in the judiciary and I
was given all that up if I decided to
join what many in the law see is the
frivolity of television of course now
that it's been on the year 20 years I'm
a genius you know but back then people
were worried about what it is that was
gonna happen in my career what you see
on the show are real small claims cases
they're lifted directly out of the
courthouse to be arbitrated by Judge
Milian if you get your case in
small-claims there's one judge and
there's three or four hundred cases that
show up on any given day and it's very
hard and possible for that one judge to
get through those cases so they offer
you something called binding arbitration
and that is you can go to a lawyer plead
your case to the lawyer with the person
you're suing and that lawyer will decide
the case it's binding arbitration
there's no room for appeal and you have
agreed and the defendant has agreed to
allow this arbitrator to
you hear your case and that's basically
exactly what we do so how do they pick
the cases this is like panning for gold
we go out and we go to all these courts
and we get all of these cases and we sit
through them we love a relationship case
we love where an ex-wife is suing their
ex-husband we love cases where there's a
lot of personal kind of stuff along with
the legal stuff so it's the
personalities that we're looking for
we're looking for a good argument we're
looking for a good defense that's how we
select our cases we shoot to bring the
public the juiciest cases we can get
they were juicy then they're juicy now
and hopefully they'll continue to be
juicy the show covers travel expenses
for the participants and will pay the
settlement if the case is ruled in your
favor but for most cases it's not really
about the money we once had a guy who
paid $40 to file a case over a five
dollar lottery card and it was a thing
of beauty
because what it shows you is that small
claims is never about the money it's
always about the principle so you've got
a case how do you get the judge on your
side absolutely the biggest mistake
people make is coming unprepared if you
want a judge to rule against somebody
and believe you you have to bring
evidence you can't just show up with
your flapping gums people will just walk
it in there
they're insulted that you didn't just
take their word for it it's insanity I
think people think that because they
believe their story so much all they
have to do is come forward and say it
and everyone else is going to see it
their way but when there's two sides
involved you know you have to prove what
it is you're saying a hot dog is a
sandwich if it's essentially two pieces
of bread with some kind of meat or salad
on the inside it's a sandwich next case